wenige tage nach der messerattacke in
melbourne feiern die australier einen
obdachlosen mann als helden
dort hatte am freitag ein attentäter in
einer belebten straße einen mann
erstochen und zwei weitere menschen
verletzt während viele passanten das
weite suchten stellt sich michael rogers
dem attentäter in den weg mit nichts
weiter als einem einkaufswagen unter dem
motto nicht alle helden tragen einen
umhang haben nun viele menschen geld für
den mutigen obdachlosen gesammelt
insgesamt kamen über 83.000 euro
zusammen die der 46 jährigen und bald
bekommen wird rogers gab sich nach der
aktion sehr bescheiden einem
australischen fernsehsender sagte er er
sei kein held er habe aber das gefühl
dass er vielleicht leben gerettet habe